hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about the hippier 8 hydrolysis
test this test is one of many different
possible biochemical tests that can be
used to distinguish different types of
bacteria based on their metabolic
capabilities and in this test in
particular hippie rate is able to be
hydrolyzed that means using water to
break bonds so hippie rate is able to be
broken down by water
if an enzyme called hippier case is
present and so if the pure case is
present it uses water to break down
hippy rate to make the products benzoic
acid and glycine glycine is something
you've probably heard of before glycine
is one of the different amino acids that
our building blocks for proteins it's
the the simplest amino acid with having
a the simplest kind of our group on it
so glycine is one of the products of
this reaction and it is the product that
in this hippie rate hydrolysis test is
detected by an oxidizing agent a
chemical known as the ninhydrin reagent
and so if glycine is present because
hippy rate has been broken down then
this will give a deep purple color to
your tube before we go on to talk about
the method let's take a minute to
mention some positive examples these are
clinically relevant examples what I mean
by that is these are examples of hippy
rate hydrolysis positive bacteria that
one might see in a patient too sick in
the hospital for example and these
include Campylobacter jejuni
Listeria monocytogenes and a few
different types of Group B Strep Turk
oxide so all of these would be able to
break down this hippy rate because they
have a hip here
now let's talk about the method the
procedure that is used to carry out this
test excuse me
you start by adding point 1 to point 2
milliliters of sterile distilled water
to a sterile test-tube that's not a lot
you know it's just kind of a few drops
to the test tube and then you've
inoculate that water with an 18 to 24
hour bacterial suspension so this is the
bacteria that has been collected from a
patient that you're trying to identify
what that bacterium is and this inoculum
does need to be quite heavy and what I
mean by that is if you don't use enough
bacteria you might get a false negative
test so you're supposed to have this 18
to 20 hour 24-hour bacterial suspension
this means that bacteria are in that
exponential growth phase they are very
healthy and happy and growing rapidly
and so you take a pretty heavy amount of
that suspension and inoculate it into
the tube then you place a rapid hippie
rate disc this is just a sterile disc it
has heavy rate on it into this mixture
so at this point all the mixture has is
the bacterial suspension and whatever
enzymes those bacteria have as well as
sterile distilled water and a rapid
heavy rate disc so there's no other
possible source of glycine which means
that when the ninhydrin reagent is added
which happens after an incubation sir
incubating not even for a very long
period of time just a couple of hours at
pretty close to human body temperature
then you add this point to milliliter
ninhydrin reagent and remember that the
ninhydrin reagent
if glycine is present it's going to
react with glycine to result in this
deep purple color so you add 0.2
milliliters of the ninhydrin reagent
incubate for 15 to 30 minutes again not
a long period of time some other
biochemical tests that are separating or
identifying bacteria based on them at
all capabilities to take a couple of
days to carry out this one you can do
same same day same afternoon so after
that second incubation of just sort of
half an hour or less you observe the
color if you have a positive bacterium
so one of these or another example of a
bacterium that's able to use heavier
case they break down heavy right that's
going to give you this deep purple sort
of violet maybe cut sometimes bluish but
this deep purple color in your tube
whereas if the bacterium is not capable
of this reaction it's not going to
produce glycine when given this hippie
rate source and that means that you're
going to have a colorless liquid in the
bottom of your tube sometimes depending
on what other things may have been
present in those negative bacteria you
might get a small color change maybe
slightly pink slightly yellow usually
colorless or a very very very faint
color nothing like the deep dark readily
recognizable purple that you get in a
positive example so if you are
interested in learning about other kinds
of biochemical tests things like the
indole test the lecithinase test the
citrate test check out my playlist on
biochemical tests to identify bacteria
and that's it for today so thank you for
watching biology professor